Trascrizione: Alessia Banka
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Ciao, volevo cominciare con una domanda:
secondo voi, qual è il soldato migliore?
Lagunari, paracadutisti, carristi -
che vi viene in mente?
Facciamo una cosa, me lo dite dopo.
Quanto è bella la guerra?
Quella che vediamo al cinema,
con quei proiettili che partono
e arrivano dritti dritti al bersaglio.
E uccidono, sempre,
solo i cattivi e mai i buoni.
Non sporcano nemmeno:
qualche macchia di sangue sulla camicia.
In realtà, però, la guerra non è così.
La guerra, nella realtà, è molto diversa.
Sapete, ci sono feriti
che se la fanno addosso:
urina, feci.
Non per paura: è una reazione al trauma.
Si chiama reazione neurologica,
"perdita del controllo degli sfinteri".
Quando poi hai la fortuna
di avere qualcuno
che dalle tue parti, in mezzo ai feriti,
è capace di rimettere assieme
i pezzi dei corpi,
succedono cose come questa.
L’arteria femorale è come un elastico.
Ci avete mai fatto caso?
Avete mai provato a rompere un elastico?
Lo rompete, e i due capi si ritirano.
Quando vieni colpito alla gamba,
se ti tagliano l’arteria femorale
chi cerca di aiutarti
deve recuperare due capi
e unirli insieme.
Spesso deve infilarti la mano nell’addome,
per cercare di recuperarla,
perché si è ritratta qui.
E quindi, il ferito perde sangue,
perché l'addome continua
a riempirsi di sangue,
perde forza e grida di dolore
perché c'è questa mano dentro
che cerca di salvarlo.
Una volta ero a Kabul, 2007:
era ancora una situazione
relativamente tranquilla,
però i giornalisti occidentali
non uscivano più dai compound.
Ed ero su un moncone di ponte,
nell’area orientale della città,
con un gruppo di giornalisti locali.
Lo ha detto il nostro presentatore, prima:
faccio il giornalista e volevo occuparmi
dell’industria turistica in Asia,
del sollevamento delle acque alle Maldive;
ma mi occupo di crisi.
Scrivo anche libri:
l’ultimo, "Maledetti pacifisti",
ha fatto arrabbiare un sacco di gente,
che è la cosa che mi riesce meglio.
Ed ero appunto su questo ponte -
essendo un ponte interrotto,
i convogli militari dovevano lasciare
la strada principale,
scendere sul greto del torrente,
rallentare e risalire.
Quindi lì, praticamente,
diventavano dei bersagli
grossi, grassi, goffi.
E quel giorno, un kamikaze con l’auto
si era lanciato in un convoglio francese,
ed era morto un militare.
E noi stavamo andando
a raccontare quella storia:
purtroppo erano morti anche,
come al solito, dei civili di passaggio.
All’improvviso, un gruppo di afgani
mi ha preso di forza, di peso,
e mi ha portato via.
E ho pensato che c’eravamo
salutati, insomma,
che era l’ultima tappa della corsa.
Invece, mi hanno portato
in una stradina laterale
a farmi vedere perché i loro negozi -
che però erano come
delle baracche di legno,
più o meno come le cabine del Lido,
degli stabilimenti balneari -
non riuscivano ad aprire.
C’era in fondo alla strada
un militare francese
che gli puntava il mitra
perché aveva paura di un secondo attacco;
e poi, davanti a una
di queste porte c’era un braccio.
Era un braccio perfettamente tagliato,
e in mano aveva ancora
il cordino dell’innesco.
Era - la balistica è una scienza strana...
Era il braccio del kamikaze,
che con l’esplosione era stato proiettato
a 500 metri di distanza,
perfettamente cauterizzato:
non aveva un una goccia di sangue.
E in realtà, oggi ci penso:
io non ho mai capito
perché è morto quel soldato francese.
Non so - era l’uomo in ralla,
cioè quello che sta mezzo fuori
e mezzo dentro con la mitragliatrice.
Non ho capito se è morto
perché è stato schiacciato dal veicolo,
dal suo mezzo che si è capovolto,
o perché è stato ucciso dall’esplosione.
In realtà sapete, nessuno muore mai
veramente per l’esplosione.
Che fa l’esplosione?
L’esplosione è un’onda d’urto,
che passando solleva qualsiasi frammento,
qualsiasi oggetto che trova -
i pezzi della blindatura, sassi,
pezzi di auto, cancelli di ferro -
qualsiasi cosa,
e li trasforma in proiettili.
Tant’è vero che i kamikaze,
da diversi anni, sapete cosa fanno?
Si riempiono il giubbotto esplosivo
di chiodi e bulloni,
così praticamente riescono
a fare molto più male.
IED è un’altra di quelle parole
che provano a rendere la guerra cool.
Io ero nella valle del fiume Pech,
provincia di Konar.
Un militare americano mi ha detto:
"Questa è la zona
più cinetica che abbiamo".
Mi sembrava una cosa bella: cinetica!
Poi ho capito che era il posto
dove morivano più americani.
E lì c’erano un sacco di esplosioni,
perché praticamente si riempivano
delle pentole a pressione di esplosivo,
le si metteva sottoterra
e poi le si faceva detonare,
o con un piatto di pressione
o con un telefonino attaccato.
Tu lo chiamavi, il telefonino squillava,
dava il contatto ed esplodeva.
È a quel punto che hai IED:
Improvised Explosive Device,
cioè delle bombe improvvisate.
Una volta, un artificiere della Folgore
mi ha fatto vedere un piatto di pressione,
quello sul quale metti
il piede sopra, ed esplode.
E in realtà era il coperchio
di un fustino del detersivo.
E voi direte: ma dove si prende
tutto questo esplosivo?
Guardate, è l’ultimo dei problemi.
In un paese in guerra,
il flusso di armi si accumula.
A un certo punto cominci  a fare
quello che, sempre nel linguaggio
"cool" della guerra, chiami cash.
Cioè prendi un sacco di tela,
prendi una cassa di legno,
la riempi di armi, la interri -
perché un giorno ti serviranno -
e quando ti serve la tiri fuori.
Prendi la granata di un mortaio,
la sviti, togli la calotta,
e riversi tutto il contenuto
nella pentola a pressione.
Poi un giorno, però,
i Ministeri alla Difesa si sono accorti
che morivano troppi soldati
seduti nei loro mezzi,
per via di queste esplosioni.
E allora hanno inventato dei veicoli
che costano un milione di dollari l’uno.
Quelli che quando si chiude
la porta fa shhhh,
come a pressione,
come quelle del Frecciarossa.
E quindi che succede?
A ogni azione c’è sempre una reazione,
è l’algebra della guerra.
Per cui capitava che in un mercato
uscisse un bambino,
correva, saltava sul cofano del veicolo,
e lanciava una granata
nella buca del mitragliere.
Oppure bisognava aumentare
la potenza dell’esplosione,
anche perché queste pentole a pressione
con i metal detector le trovavano.
E allora si è cominciato a usare
il nitrato d’ammonio,
che era sempre più potente.
Quindi, insomma, "la sicurezza",
come se la guerra fosse un cantiere.
E poi, siamo arrivati
di nuovo alla domanda:
qual è il soldato perfetto?
Ve lo dico io: è la mina.
La mina è perfetta.
La mina non mangia, non dorme,
non va in licenza - cioè in ferie -
e non va in pensione:
lavora fino all’ultimo giorno
della sua vita, quando esplode.
E però, non diamo
tutto il merito alle mine:
Quando c’è un bombardamento,
in un pezzo di terreno ci sono centinaia,
a volte migliaia di ordigni inesplosi.
Io lo ricordo: il bambino era nel letto,
la bambina era in piedi.
Erano due bambini afgani,
erano usciti a fare legna.
Era marzo, quando la neve si scioglie
e il terreno si smuove.
Erano andati a fare legna:
però avevano trovato, anche,
una pallina metallica.
I bambini afgani non pensano
ai giocattoli, e hanno detto:
"Questa può aiutarci a riscaldare casa”.
Sono tornati a casa,
l’hanno buttata dentro,
e ora stavano di fronte a me.
Erano lui nel lettino.
Lei lo vegliava.
A lui mancavano tutte e due le mani,
perché quella pallina
era l’acino di una bomba cluster.
La bomba cluster è come
un grappolo di uva, e si butta a terra.
È come avere in mano
un barattolo di biglie,
che cadono tutt'intorno -
però poi esplodono.
Quella non era esplosa:
o meglio, è esplosa nelle mani
di quei due bambini.
E non è una novità:
è la norma trovare,
in un ospedale di guerra -
era quello di Emergency a Kabul -
bambini pluriamputati.
Una volta ho visto un bimbo di sei anni
con una scheggia in testa.
Bambini, per un proiettile vagante,
donne, quindi sicuramente
non combattenti, vecchi,
sono stati tetraplegici, paraplegici.
E infatti io credo che tutti coloro
i quali stanno per assumere un incarico
che consenta loro
di poter far partire una guerra,
tutti i politici dovrebbero passare
un pomeriggio in un ospedale di guerra,
per vedere quali sono poi
gli effetti delle guerre.
Attenzione: ho detto in grado
di "far partire" una guerra,
perché nessuno è in grado di fermarla.
Noi ci illudiamo di scoperchiare
il vaso di Pandora
e i demoni che ne escono fuori
possiamo portarli al guinzaglio.
La guerra poi, purtroppo,
vive della della sua vita autonoma,
e va avanti così
e non riusciamo a fermarla.
Io ho due figli, Alex e Caterina.
E dico sempre loro
di non giocare con i soldatini,
perché sono una grande bugia.
Voi direte: "Pure i soldatini!".
I soldatini di plastica non si sporcano,
non cacciano sangue.
Uno è morto, lo tiri su ed è vivo:
sono una grande balla.
Provate ad andare
in un negozio di soldatini,
e comprare una scatola di civili.
Potete comprare paracadutisti, carristi,
incursori della marina, fanteria,
lagunari, quello che volete -
non potete comprare i civili.
Non potete comprare la mamma
che va al pozzo a prendere l’acqua,
non potete comprare
i bambini che vanno a scuola,
i genitori che vanno a lavorare.
Sono queste, le vittime della guerra.
Su dieci, tra morti e feriti,
nove sono civili,
anche se poi non ce lo raccontano mai.
Ci vogliono sempre far credere -
perché la guerra è un prodotto:
ha bisogno del marketing,
per essere venduta alle nostre coscienze -
che la guerra sia morale,
giusta, inevitabile.
E ti dicono "Si vis pacem, para bellum":
Se vuoi la pace, prepara la guerra.
Che poi è una frase di 2500,
forse non lo so, millemila anni fa.
E in questo tempo, forse,
l’uomo è pure cambiato,
le cose saranno pure cambiate:
però continuiamo a ripetercela.
Io credo invece che la frase giusta sia:
“Se vuoi la pace, conosci la guerra”.
E insomma, tanto mi dispiace
che ve l’ho messa giù così cruda.
Ma questa è la verità.
La guerra è merda,
distruzione, morte e sangue.
Non c’è nient’altro.
Non c’è niente di epico.
Non c’è niente di romantico.
Non c’è niente di eroico.
Questa è la guerra.
Purtroppo però,
per vendercela ce la nascondono.
C’è il marketing della guerra,
perché la guerra genera profitti
per pochi soggetti,
e li genera subito.
La pace crea profitti per tutti noi,
ma a lungo termine.
Ed è un po' come il giardino pubblico:
che fa bene a tutti, è di tutti:
però, poi, lo trattiamo
come fosse di nessuno.
L’Italia sta vivendo il più lungo
periodo di pace nella sua Storia,
che coincide col massimo
periodo di ricchezza:
eppure, nessuno si prende cura della pace.
Continuiamo a parlare di guerra
come fosse una cosa semplice,
una cosa che poi riusciamo a gestire,
che poi tutto sommato ce la caviamo,
è breve, è giusta.
E purtroppo, non è così.
La guerra è la cosa più ingiusta che c’è.
Per questo oggi parliamo di nuovi inizi,
e io credo che l’unico nuovo inizio
che può avere il genere umano
è liberarsi per sempre
della guerra, abolirla.
Diceva una persona, la cui voce
oggi ci manca più che mai,
un mio caro amico, una figura
che mi ha ispirato tanto: Gino Strada.
Diceva:
"Se l’uomo non caccia
la guerra dalla storia,
sarà la guerra a cacciare
l’uomo dalla Storia".
Io spero che questo
ce lo ricordiamo tutti quanti noi.
Grazie.
(Applausi)